kherson melitopol berdyansk but the top
reality in these places and rural towns is a
novel that they kick out another one to
drive out the occupiers with my
own decision I will decide with my poverty the freedom square kherson
c all ukraine rumble these konotop y
mysteries shout at the occupiers c ukraine
ukraine yaku we know u i think to anyone
we protect and not the view of the house to the greedy thief those about
snotty heroism to protest and cool and
your places and the bathhouse and h & m hours
knee-wave your armor and to be with they
will tell you with arrows and you don’t run
naked take off your armor she’s you and diopter and
you don’t look like you go yourself to this  the buyer of
tem watches, she’s a piece of our people, our
Ukrainians don’t step on the
bottom, they start carting against the bottom and
shouting to the invaders and the misfortune of the thought of
Donbass,
remember, as you were told Donbass,
no one kneeled and no one
was given these
words in Donetsk words in Luhansk  everyone knows they were often
repeated before and that now the Donbass
now is the time we appeal to all
people in the temporarily occupied
territories  to all those who hear us who have
not been erased the memory of propaganda who have not been
closed their eyes with fear who have not been
mutilated by cynicism fight
for their rights for their freedom
for Ukraine together with Kherson together with
Berdyansk together with Kiev and all
other Ukrainian cities that
value life
they are afraid  In total, I know that many of
you believed that Ukraine allegedly
hates you, allegedly will attack, allegedly
will destroy, lies on Russian
television,
they talk about it every day, maybe it’s their
job to lie to you every day, but this
should not be your fate, just
compare Donetsk after eight years of war  and
Kharkov, after eight days of the war,
they told you that we are destroying cities
look at the ferrets look at
blueberries at 500 kilogram bombs
that dropped on the houses of Ukrainians
killed us killed children on the beard
on broken schools on blown up
kindergartens on the broken Kharkiv Assumption
Cathedral on what for everything  this is what
Russia did,
it's the same with  did it before your eyes
so defend yourself otherwise it will take both
your life and your houses ukraine
does not shoot its own we do not blow up residential buildings and
everyone in the donbass for us has always been and
will be Ukrainians our people our
citizens near Donetsk Luhansk well
they are ready for Berdyansk  to that and the goose of
our places the goose of their places of our holding
in ukraine glory to ukraine